the jurogan experience
so
when did you know
that you wanted to be a chef like how
long have you been like really into
cooking because you're a young guy by
the way congratulations on the michelin
stars thank you that's i think that's
giant right in the world of chefs that's
that's the [ __ ] thing right yeah um i
i mean i dedicated the last
probably 15 years of my life just to
trying to get a michelin star and uh
when i found out this year uh
they had me on a on a zoom call they
kind of they kind of lied to me they
kind of uh what they did is they said uh
we wanted they said first of all i said
you're not gonna you're not getting a
star this year just so you know but we
want to have uh send someone to the
restaurant in los angeles and um we have
some interview questions we want to ask
you about uh you know how it was to
operate during coven
and i said well i'm in austin but i i
can fly back and like no no big deal
don't fly back just just zoom in so i
zoom in and they have my wife uh who's
our pastry chef and my business partner
um she's at the restaurant and so is my
brother who was the chef of
sushi bar and montecito uh and our chef
at pasta bar and they're all three there
uh just in the restaurant and i'm
at my house here in austin and i'm on
zoom and they start asking us some
random questions about uh you know how
is it you know what's it like being open
and what if the the the you know
pitfalls you had to overcome
and uh then out of nowhere they just go
oh and um i have one extra question um
uh congratulations uh
two of your restaurants are getting
michelin stars oh they snuck it in on it
they snuck it in and i'm on and the
thing is i'm on a zoom and so i was like
wait what what did she say like i
couldn't i couldn't hear and and
everyone's it and i thought we had just
gotten one and it turned out they said
no no no i said wait which rest which
restaurant they said sushi bar montecito
and
uh uh and pasta bar
and uh i just pasta bars in l.a pasta
bars in l.a and um i just started crying
wow yeah so i was just reading uh on the
history of the michelin star and that it
was really back in the early days of
travel they had a book would show you
where you can get your car repaired
where you could refuel
and then where you get something to eat
yeah and then people got really obsessed
with the where to get something to eat
part and then it became a separate
entity it was never i don't think they
ever set out to become
the world's standard
on cuisine i don't think that was ever
the point the point was we have to give
you a reason to buy tires and that
reason is to drive and so here's some
things to drive to and so that's what
the one star two star three star you
know delineations have to have to do
with is this one is worth you know a
stop this one's worth a detour and this
one's worth a journey and so that's how
you get one star two-star three-star so
one star means if it's on your way stop
that was over a hundred years ago now
one star means you know fly there but
three star means like up end your life
and go figure like go find that place
what's what's that who's got three stars
uh here in america not many mcdonald's
mcdonald's yeah i think they have i
think they have four stars actually
is there is there uh anywhere in america
that has three uh yeah a couple couple
places like what
uh the french laundry has three stars
okay that's that place where gavin
newsom got in trouble right i watched a
video on that um not on that but on uh
bourdain when bourdain uh i think it was
the old show i think it wasn't even i
think it was no real reservations yeah
and he went to french laundry it was
pretty [ __ ] incredible yeah i've only
got to eat there once but it's i mean
it's a it's an institution
it's that good oh yeah oh yeah i mean
it's it's it for a long time it was the
restaurant in america um
the it was the restaurant isn't it kind
of a weird spot like you got to travel
yeah but that's part of sort of the
allure of
and not to say they wouldn't be a
three-star restaurant without you know
having that uh that part of traveling
but three stars is when you're worth the
journey
and um so you could be in like the
himalayas or some show yeah i mean a lot
of some of the three star restaurants
around the world are not in you know
they're not in strip malls they're not
in city centers they're you know they've
bought ranches they've bought uh you
know they have land uh el bully was on
the top of a mountain
where's el bulli well that's been closed
for a long time but that was in spain oh
yeah yeah so i mean they're saying that
like i know i don't know any this listen
you let me into your world i don't know
what you're talking about what's
elbowing
so that was fair and adria
they
they were named best restaurant in the
world
several years over
it was really the restaurant that
uh really brought what became known as
molecular gastronomy the all the food
that's that you know jamie would
probably look at and say this is what
what am i looking at this doesn't look
like food this looks like
interesting abstract art
but you know they think you know today
you have restaurants where you know
you'll get
literally a balloon that's brought out
to the table and you
eat the suck the helium out and eat the
balloon and that's you know
one of the courses
oh wow 12 iconic dishes of el bulli
um
so this is like fancy dining and this is
like it's beyond fancy dining from
jamie's lineage would look about this
and
if you asked him is that like what is
this and you didn't tell him it was you
wouldn't think that was food
yeah jamie's not into this i could tell
already it's a sea urchin that that is
sea urchin
delicious do you like sea urchins no of
course i just tried octopus recently and
yeah okay i feel bad eating octopus
because i found how [ __ ] smart i know
that's what i thought i was like i'll
try it so i can say i tried it but
they're but they're
you know they're so [ __ ] good they're
very good but there are murderers i mean
they murder everything yeah i'd rather
have
macaroni and cheese and steak oh my god
macaroni and cheese i'm just saying i'd
rather have something else